the ball utah now their bench is just  two out of 12 from beyond the arc  ross throw it down  throw it down russ  down the middle he goes then he gets a  technical for ponding but  i mean he looked back at rudy gobert  and handsome  with some words that was so close that's  what russ  has been known for doing though  getting into the paint and then  exploding did he ever explode  over the top of gobert  oh wow that's just a monster dunk  by russell westbrook  crowd up  wow  and that was a trampoline act there by  russell westbrook i mean this is what  we've seen his entire career we always  talk about everything's predicated on  his explosiveness to the rim